wir schauen auf 117 lange tage krieg sie
haben gerade die bilder schon gesehen
ein krieg ohne pause für diesen
ukrainischen soldaten wenigstens dieser
kurze moment des glücks schauen sie das
wiedersehen mit dem eigenen sohn
doch der krieg hat seit einigen wochen
diese geschichte im osten geht der
ukraine dorf für dorf straße um straße
verloren und dorthin in den osten des
landes hat sich paul ronzheimer
aufgemacht in die region in der die
heftigsten kämpfe gerade stattfinden
bild reporter paul ronzheimer eben nie
pro aktuell paul ich habe gerade schon
gesagt die geschichte dorf für dorf
straße für straße geht verloren ist das
das was du dort gerade vor ort auch sie
ist und kannst du uns schildern mit
welchem tempo aktuell die russische
armee sich dort vor kämpft
ich stehe am friedhof in die pro und das
ist der alltag geworden hier hinter mir
frische gräber teilweise aus den letzten
tagen aus den letzten wochen überall an
den friedhöfen wenn man weiter richtung
osten fährt sieht man diese gräber viele
ukrainische flaggen am wochenende hat es
die beerdigung von roman oder schnee
gegeben einem aktivisten einem helden
nur 24 jahre alt und kurz nach dieser
beerdigung hat sein vater gesagt ich
muss wieder los weg aus kiew zurück an
die front die front die ist hier weiter
östlich wir sind auf dem weg dorthin
anthony pro macht man sozusagen
zwischenstation und dann fährt man von
hier noch mal drei vier stunden weiter
richtung don was es ist so dass die
russische armee massiv versucht hat
offenbar ukrainische generäle und
offiziere zu treffen angeblich so sagt
die sagen russische medien da muss man
sehr vorsichtig sein seien aber bis zu
50 generäle und offiziere getötet worden
die ukraine haben dass weder dementiert
noch bestätigt definitiv gibt es
angriffe und was im osten passiert also
rund um die don't ask region da muss man
sich sorgen machen denn die russische
armee rückt weiter vor du hast jetzt
paul ja die ganzen politischen treffen
gerade in kiew erlebt also ursula von
der leyen die kommissionschefin der rudi
da war und dann vor allen dingen dieses
treffen des kanzlers der mit makro und
dem italienischen ministerpräsidenten
draghi dorthin gereist war eben
nachgefasst all diese politischen
treffen verfolgt wenn dort jetzt im
osten mit den menschen spricht kannst du
er den menschen hoffnung aus kiew
mitbringen oder im grunde das gefühl
dass das zu einer vergessenen region
wird
ich traue mich das nicht den menschen zu
sagen das kommt jetzt wirklich was da
angekündigt wurde oder es kommt mehr
denn wir wissen ja unser kanzler hat
sehr viel versprochen unsere
bundesregierung hat sehr viel
versprochen und die ukraine hatten immer
wieder hoffnung dass es sich jetzt
ändert dass es jetzt anders wird das
jetzt eben nicht mehr so viele menschen
sterben müssen sondern sie sich
verteidigen können und häufig wurde
diese hoffnung enttäuscht also so
richtig glaubt noch niemand dran man
setzt jetzt darauf dass amerikanische
das amerikanische hilfe endlich kommt
damit sich etwas ändert danke paul
ronzheimer in den osten der ukraine
weiter auf dem weg dorthin richtung
donbass danke dir